>>APPY GLOOUS DNESY.
Y NUMBERHREE OF NIN STUDI
AUDICE.
YOUON'TEAR LAUGER
FOLLOWG MYMAZI JESUST
INYOU' WCHINSOMEDY
SE D STANDUP
SE IN POT JU NOW
MEMBER TANC TT WA
>> TS G I KNOIT'SOI TO
BLOWOUR ND.
HE ACTLLY CAPEFR NOT
BEG INRISO WCH I KNO
SEEMPOINESS.
T H FLED  COMY WITH E
CONDITNS OHISELSE.
D OFCEHAT TS ME
IMINS OFF.
SIWALKOULDE CONSIREDR.WDSSNDANG.
IS NOW SSIN LE PTY
SHHE DIDOT CHECKN.
IS RPRING.
IEVER THOHT YOUOULDREESOTHINMORE
NG.
BUTHO COULDAVE SEE TS
COMI?
ENTIRESSUEAS TDOITH A
IT INOT A FENY AON.
'S AENCENDEREW YORK W
ANYBY COULD VE SN TH
CONG.
EY HE SEEN T ERRS IN
INSTD  REVSING
DERUCTE PRACTE THE ARE
TRICING WN.
STORSBOUT T NEW TOU ON
CRIMMAYO THEEW PGRESVE
IS AORY WILLOT SK
ISONOR MT IMES
LAWS SUPRTINPOLI LIKE A
TEBED.
AER A SSH A GRAB IS
REOMMO THAA STORE.
IT MAK NO NSE.
'S OERHEM  STO
EKINA COLOR ARLESENTCE
R ANHI SHO OF RDER.
LESSOU AISMEERIN A
MILYNHEIRRONTAWN AT
NO IS N GNG TBE IN
LI WH JL TE.
ERE'AWNFORCEME THAKI OFEW YK DE.
YOU OW WT I'M TAING OUT.
I'M SU THERIMES ING OPHEY THEARS
ING NS AND OER BINESS
LY F PET LCENY
D MDEMEOR.
WLD N WANTO BE A SHIEATOW.
IMALS TTINCAUGHT WH
WEAPONOTHETHANUNAVEFENY CRGESOWO
SDEMNORS
INSTEADF CALLI ABOHE
MEDI ISROBABLY ING  ENJ
THIS
R
A FRH CANNA POIN.
AWFUINED.
ANDUSTIKE BIRTHDAYARTY
JUSTE HA BEEN SVED.
BA TO YOU EG.
YO M BE THINNG TS IS
TYCAL STUP THI.
U SULDN'T BLIVIHE.
'S NO LOER INEWORK CITY
IS ERICA.
ACCOING  A VTIADVOTE
OUP THE BN RELEAS ON
MULTLE FONY BOND
TH HE MDERE56 PPLE
SIE 28.
PREVENTESEURDE HAVBE
LE GTO TAS WRE KIDS VE
GUN CKS.
ONDE WHABLACK PELE TNK
GUTFD. WNG WITHHE RAD?
HEOUTFE.
I AANGR
YOUHOULBE ANGRYS WE.
SOMEDY COULDET UIN T
MOING ANDO TO BUIING
BURNED OA CHSTMATREE THA
PEOPLE M BE RSE.N O
B OUT INIME  GET
MARSALLO IN THEMOERINFLES.
ARMED ROERY IONEF TH
WOT THGSOU C GO UGH.
TH RUNHEINNEBELL
WE WLD ND  BE EPAR.
AM GRY.
LESS WE ART R OW
ANCRIMMOMENT W ARE INTROUE.
INK OUT AT TOMORW AS
OTHE NWORK DL WITH E
ANHINGHAT  GOING TGO CONDEM
LIDATE ATHIN WIT Y.
LEING E PSON DEATE
TS
OUWILDUDIENCEOINGRAZY
PEONALITIEARE ECTR.
SON CRAF
THEUCKTOPSERTHATS WHA
ONCEGA Y HE ODONEBACKETORASHHE Y
YOURLF WH YOUR WDROBYOLOOKIKE AA
YO ARE LIK T COURT JTER THMEDDNE
IS PTTY GH
ARE U WOING OUT O DIDOU
T ANOTHE VERON OYOURSELF
YOU WE A B DRER.
U KW WHA IIS LEO B
MUGG.
I JT WT TSAY THISUICK.
OPLELWAYS ASK D YOU PROLE
EN Y ARERIVING AAB?
U'REURE DRIVG A B 1
HOS PER D YOU MUSWANTO
E.
HOST IF YBODIS WATCHG
ATOME MHT WT TO TRY
AT HARDE
THEY A REAY DOG SOMETHG
ENVINMENTH ISOREAT AN
THEICTIM DO Y RECL THEN
FAUS TSHEY E NOCALLED
HAIR BEI CHAD.
AT'S WHYE ISUSA
PANDERG PEON.
THONEHINGLOQUENT OUT
IS NOT T RES OF XAHEOUNT
ITS LIKE ATIN TH AHOWER.
I WOPIN YOU WOU NOTOINTTHISUT.
ATS AOLE  MY MONOGUE.
>> JON Y ACTUAY LE I
THCITYUTOT Y HAVMOVED
OUPELEAMEERE BECSEOU AALWED  CO.
THATS THE WHOOINTF BEG
OUNDEOPLE BU YOU WERPRECTEWH ISN
TY?
>> HESY I VE CE HERE
YBE TWICPER AR F
CHSTMAS.
BIRTHDAYN LY F HS MY WIF
TH KNO THA THEY WI BE T.WH IS E?
>> ING CK TPENNSYLVIA.
WHDIDHIS HAPP?
ONEHING THAHASAPPENED
HAT IT HASECE
FASHNABLFOR THEEMOCTS T
TA THIS POTIONHAT
MOCRS SULD BE CDLED
WI ?
THERSEEMS TOE A OGRA
TALKIN ABO THEARS REAL
ESTATE
IT'S N THATHEYER
IMISON A NOTUILT
HEAS AAID  SEE WHAWOULHAEN ITHEY
THERE' GOI TOE LOTF
OPLEHATAY N YORK ISOT
THAT B.
GUEN MAHA'S VINARD?
LARGEST E F NEWORKERS.TH HAV BEY
NCERD WI THEAR.
DEMOATS E TEING THEM WE
CATOU HAVE EN AROPONTITHMEDIND .
I DIGREE.
SO OF THESDRUGEALE THE
ARMED BBER THI F EXALE.YOSHOU G.
AMENENT THI THE HAV ER
DONE.
WH SOMODY
HIELF TH AUN THEYRE
WEINHE CY RIGHT W IFOU
HAVE A ARM ROBRYOINGN
E WOD PULLER WPON AND
OOTHE Y.
WOU N DO LL IPRISON.
>>T ISRUE.
THE ORAGCOMPANIE AREOING
ORLSE EY A GOING TGO OOFUSINS.
WE D THESE ECTR BICLE
EXRTS.
E CMEAVE CAMEERY REAL
ME.
I HA BEETO HOW D THIS
EV HAPPEN?
RIGHOUTSE THE REAURA
BRKINGN AND TANG I AWA
SOMEBO SAI TRE A TCKS.